>> The rest of the notion of indexing,
let's go back to our navigation world.
Imagine that we already have cases A,
B, C and D.
We might use a very simple
indexing scheme to begin with.
We might say well simply index each
case with its initial location and
the initial location will have a X
coordinate and a Y coordinate.
So the case A may be indexed by its
initial location, which is 3E and
9N and similarly for B, C and D.
Now imagine that we have a new case,
X of going from the office
to the restaurant.
Recall that we're indexing cases right
now very simply by the XY coordinates of
the initial location.
So in index case X by the XY coordinates
of the initial location here.
Let me repeat,
this is really a very simple
indexical scheme we are using here.
As we learned in the lesson last time,
we really should be using a more
complicated indexical scheme,
which takes into account both the
initial location and final locations.
Nevertheless, this can raise
the basic notion of an index.
An index is like a tag.
At least in principle, we could come
up with which index equals key for
this particular class of problems?
We don't have to limit our social
suggesting numerical coordinates of
the initial and the goal locations.
For example, in this navigation
MicroWorld, the indexes may include
whether they are scenic or not scenic,
whether their route is fast or not fast.
>> So going back to our programming
example we were working with file input
and we could have a very rich indexical
structure for organizing cases of file
input according to various
different parameters and variables.
For example,
I might tag the individual cases
of file input according to
whether I use Java, Python, C++.
I might tag them according to whether
there were very fast or very slow and
I tagged them according to what
kind of file they read in.
Did they read text?
Did they read XML?
Did they read some other
kind of file format?
Each of those value then becomes
a particular way of identifying each
individual case, such that when I'm
given a new problem, I can find the most
similar case by seeing which one
matches the most of those variables.
>> That's an important point.
We want to use an indexical structure,
which allows for effective and
efficient retrieval,
because we are storing things only,
because we want to retrieve
them at a later time.
In case of design more generally, people
have developed indexical structures
that have to do with functions,
with operating environment,
with performance criteria and so on.